okay thank you very much and I'm honored
to be joined by representatives of many
great American retail companies some of
the greatest companies anywhere in the
world and we're talking today about
different things and including
distribution and medical diagnostics etc
you'll see in a second they're gonna say
hello 45 days ago many of you joined me
in the Rose Garden to launch a new
partnership with the private sector to
dramatically increase and accelerate
America's capacity to test for the
coronavirus we've made such strides like
it wouldn't even be you wouldn't even
believe it we just had a call with the
governor's and I guess they were just
about all on the call and everybody was
very happy and the testing is going
really well
we're beating we're doing more than
anybody else probably some of you are on
that call even though you aren't
supposed to be but I'm sure you were and
the testing itself is going very well
no complaints since then what we've
achieved is really nothing short of
amazing the United States now holds the
world record for testing and by a lot
we've conducted more than 5.4 million
tests more than any other country
anywhere in the world and we're actually
growing it very rapidly you probably
heard those numbers just came out after
encouraging governors for several weeks
to leverage unused testing capacity in
their states
last week we provided contact
information for specific labs where they
could find additional testing and
capacity within 48 hours the number of
tests performed across the country began
to skyrocket early in April the United
States averaged approximately 150,000
tests per day that's up very very
substantially from a couple of weeks
before and the 150,000 a day has gone to
way over 200,000 tests per day since
Wednesday this includes a one hundred
and twenty two percent testing increase
in Michigan one hundred and twenty four
percent increase in Maryland and many
other locations are right in that
vicinity and some are a little bit
higher than that to provide further
guidance and support to the states today
where release
a blueprint for state testing plans and
rapid response programs together we're
accelerating testing for Americans at
retail locations across the country and
especially in our african-american and
Hispanic communities we're going very
very strong in those communities they're
currently 73 retail sites testing sites
and 25 states in those they're in those
specific areas and we're increasing
adverse substantially a lot of a lot of
progress has been made for African
American testing Hispanic American
testing and Asian American testing so I
look forward to hearing from each of
these incredible business people who've
worked so strongly with us right from
the beginning I think of it it was only
45 days ago that we got together in so
much progress has been made I thought
maybe would go around the room and to
take just a couple of words and then
we're having a news conference in the
Rose Garden because we have a lot of
these folks are going to be joining us
and they'll say something out there
they've got a big gift to our nation and
to the people from some of the companies
and I appreciate it we'll start off with
a very small company reversible a little
retailing company known as Walmart
headed by a great guy Doug please Doug
McMillon with Walmart I see Larry Marlow
cbsl Steve Bruce Johnson the quest
Diagnostics Richard Ashworth Walgreens
Marc Casper Thermo Fisher Scientific
Rodney MacMullen Kroger John and Em's of
us cotton here we're Donegan rite-aid
okay and we know this gentleman right so
tremendous progress is made and we'll be
talking to you a little while out at the
news conference Mike would you have
anything to say well just a word of
thanks mr. president
it's remarkable to think you speak about
45 days ago when we brought many of
these retailers together with these
remarkable commercial labs and we build
on a public-private partnership that you
forged early in the corona virus
epidemic mr. president when when we
first sat down at your direction with
these great commercial labs on March the
4th our country had conducted roughly
25,000 coronavirus tests today that
number is a 5.4 million and with the
support of companies like CVS health and
Walmart Walgreens Target and others
we're now scaling that working with
governor's as they implement their
testing plans and it really is what what
you said early on mr. president this is
a whole of America approach you brought
all of America's best together our
retailers brought together our
commercial laboratories and the results
speak for themselves as we heard on the
call with the governors today governors
are rapidly expanding testing across the
states as they move toward a phased and
responsible reopening of their state in
this nation's economy so I'm just I'm
glad to be back with this group mr.
president I know how grateful you are
for the collaboration around this table
and I look forward to hearing how we can
continue to build even more momentum in
in the progress that we're making as a
nation working with these great
retailers and working with these
extraordinary commercial labs that have
done so much for America in such a short
period of time thank you very much Mike
we'll see you outside at the news
conference thank you very much